ciao, lo so che
la finale dell'euro 2020 è stata facile
per tutti c'erano alcuni
litigi e rivolte alcuni percosse
c'erano alberi lanciati fuori dalle
finestre c'erano birre lanciate
in aria c'erano alcuni
tatuaggi sconsiderati in anticipo per cui la
gente
fischiava  tipo 75 minuti di fila
contro
qualsiasi cosa la squadra italiana abbia fatto anche
vedendo il proprio inno nazionale ci sono stati
alcuni commenti razzisti nei confronti della
squadra
inglese da parte di inglesi bene dall'altra parte
di quello che so che era
anche duro c'era kellini che tirava una maglietta oh
yeah e di  certo che stavo vincendo
so che perdere non è mai facile
so qualcosa sto rimbalzando ho
perso molto e quello che faccio quando le cose
vanno davvero male
è cucinarmi un buon pasto oggi
voglio fare pace con l'inghilterra per poter
festeggia
questo momento farò un
piatto italiano ma in versione inglese solo per
dimostrare che possiamo essere gentili l'uno con l'altro
il piatto che ho deciso di cucinare è un
capolavoro italiano è una carbonar  a vengo
da roma
e questa commedia in particolare è da roma
e in
realtà sono il re della carbonara
autoproclamato ma quello che volevo fare
oggi
era provare la versione inglese ed è per
questo che ho scelto la ricetta di jamie's oliver tra l'
altro jamie's oliver  è ancora ricercato in
alcune parti d'italia
quindi se lo vedi per favore tienilo lontano
dal paese solo per sicurezza
senza ulteriori indugi
iniziamo elencando gli ingredienti
per una carbonara inglese quello che ci serve
è un uovo che è un buon inizio per  sii
onesto
ben fatto inghilterra un po' di pepe macinato
ben fatto sono orgoglioso di te
del cheddar sai cosa non sono qui
per giudicare voglio essere il più
aperto possibile così
cheddar la mia anima sta iniziando a dolere
pancetta un rametto di rosmarino che può essere
usato come
distributore di acqua santa in una sorta di
rituale spero
aglio perché olio d'oliva bravo ragazzo
e pasta ragazzi oggi è davvero caldo qui dentro
quindi fammi fare una pausa inizio a
cucinare andiamo  andando tutti insieme
da th  Molto prima di iniziare questo era uno
scherzo ok se vieni in italia e
loro cercano di venderti un piatto di pasta
come una carbonara per 20 euro è solo
per i turisti che cercano di truffarti,
quindi vai a farti
[ __ ] prima  di tutto voglio ringraziare
non conosco questo
punto com delle shetland di Berlino per aver fornito
la ricetta della carbonara britannica di jamie jamie oliver è
venuto da una cucina per una visita e ha condiviso
alcune ricette con noi
dal suo nuovo libro di cucina salva con jamie
che presto diventerà
save jamie  temo solo per tua
informazione che questo programma non sia uno
spettacolo professionale, in realtà è uno
spettacolo di merda
quindi non aspettarti che io sia
specifico
e professionista al riguardo come molti blogger di cibo
e cuochi su Internet fingono di essere
la prima cosa  dobbiamo solo
cuocere la pasta perché la usiamo
come quelle lisce sai che questo
genere di
cose è illegale in italia dovevo andare al
mercato nero
per far andare questi ragazzi per
favore non  t
andare per Alicia perché non so  oh perché
affettare la pancetta e friggerla in una padella calda con un
filo di olio d'oliva perché sono un filo
di olio d'oliva hai già questo
hai già un grasso un filo
che è oh merda quindi sto cercando di tagliarlo
ruvido
i'  mi dispiace davvero per aver ottenuto una
pancetta così sottile, non volevo andare dal
macellaio
dato che non riuscivo davvero a trovare le
eruzioni cutanee reali
non giudicherò troppo duramente su queste
perché
sai se non hai la cosa reale
non puoi davvero giudicare la cosa reale
quindi sì mi dispiace sono pigro ora che la
pancetta
è dorata e un po' croccante dobbiamo andare ad
aggiungere l'aglio ragazzi è come
spezzare il cuore
è peggio della fine di titanic
sai quando
Leo canta lentamente sul fondo
dell'oceano bene la stessa cosa che farò
ora guarderò questo aglio
affondare lentamente e quell'oceano di grasso e tenerlo
insieme facciamolo
[Musica]
italia se tu'  Riguardando non vieni per
me ma l'odore è davvero buono ah
un pizzico di pepe prendiamo un rametto di
rosmarino  ry okay
ecco a voi ora diamo una bella mescolata
e spegniamo
il fuoco, la cosa più difficile da fare è
preparare
quell'iconica salsa carbonaro che deve essere
cremosa e di formaggio
e uova e giallo aranciato ma faremo
alla maniera britannica  quindi iniziamo con il
cheddar quindi
proviamo a farlo funzionare e a dare il meglio
penso che possiamo farlo bene non è troppo
difficile oh sì
oh sì questo è davvero abbastanza
soddisfacente ora la prossima cosa che dobbiamo fare
è aggiungere un uovo a  il cheddar che è
la cosa che mi rende
più nervoso in questo momento perché
non c'è il pecorino che è la cosa a cui
sono abituato
ho solo un po' paura di farcela il
tempo è scaduto scoliamo la pasta
questo è  la cosa che facciamo
qui dono qualcosa che fa il resto
del mondo ma quando
scoli la pasta dato che l'acqua è molto
molto calda
come quella bollente di solito lasciamo scorrere come l'
acqua fredda per non danneggiare lo
scarico
non lo so nemmeno  se in realtà parlassi
inglese, ma spero che
tu capisca  d ora riaccendiamo il fuoco
sui
condimenti non so cosa sia successo
quindi per favore ok
ok e ora l'ultimo momento
il momento che è davvero difficile da guardare
immagina di
essere qui e di doverlo davvero
aggiungere l'uovo la cosa che jamie
dice che devi spegnere il fuoco
altrimenti diventeresti come uova strapazzate ben cotte
jamie mescola aspetta dieci secondi voglio dire
è così che lo faccio quindi
dieci nove otto sette sei
cinque tre no quattro tre
due uno andiamo
[  Musica]
[Musica]
[Applausi]
non so come mi sento riguardo a questa salsa
perché è molto cremosa nello stesso
momento in cui la sollevi
vedi puoi vedere che ha tipo 10
esercizi che vado  per provarlo e vedere cosa
jeremy oliver considera una carbonara britannica
quindi questo è il risultato finale e lo
assaggerei e descriverei il sapore come
farebbe la nigella
gesù e um voglio ficcarlo in
gola
sentire il calore l'umidità il  l'umidità
scende fino in
fondo i miei granati dio salvi il  io e la regina
ok alcune cose sono davvero sbagliate come
il tipo di pasta
orribile non mi dispiace la salsa come il
tipo di formaggio cheddary appiccicoso anche se non è
affatto carbonara non è quella
italiana ovviamente è britannica il tipo di
pasta  come puoi mangiarlo
perché lo mangi perché lo compri
cosa hai suggerito a
Jamie a che cazzo stavi pensando
quando hai detto mini stronzate gli
do un
sei su dieci
cinque non è la mia tazza di tè ragazzi  amici
spero vi sia piaciuto non sono abituato a
girare video in inglese mi scuso
se ho fatto qualche errore o se ho detto
qualcosa di
sbagliato non è la mia lingua madre quindi si
per favore ai miei amici italiani
ma torniamo a voi se vi è piaciuto quello
puoi iscriverti a questo canale
o imparare a fare la vera carbonara
cliccando mi
piace qui è in italiano quindi
fammi sapere se vuoi averne una
versione inglese magari su un altro canale
perchè non voglio metterci troppo
inglese qui, quindi questa era solo una prova
spero stiate tutti bene
e vi mando un bacio
ciao ragazzi sono john matto
troppo non è molto cattivo ma non è
bravo non è una carbonara è una ma persona
in lingua italiana non molto bene ciao
ragazzi io  sono
rico e proverò questa carbonara se puoi
nominarla carbonara scusa per il mio cattivo
inglese l'odore è
davvero buono mi piace